♪♪
Emily:
3-2-1.
Good evening,
I'm, Emily Dickinson.
♪♪
Hailee:
Using Emily Dickinson's poetry
as a-a starting point
for anything creative, results
in pure wildness.
Alena:
My goal with this series is
always to be using the
life and work of Emily Dickinson,
as a kind of fun house mirror for what we
are going through
as people today.
A quiet night in, baby.
Novels and chill.
♪♪
Hailee:
After season one, Emily
can call herself a writer.
You really are a poet.
Hailee:
With season two, the changing
pace of media and technology
Hailee:
that sort of lead to this
explosion of celebrity culture
is what I was really excited to dig into.
This is a crazy time to be alive.
Why do things have to change?
Alena: This season really revolves around
Emily's struggle with whether or
not she wants to become famous.
You deserve to be seen, Emily.
Hailee: After season one, Sue has
transformed into
this glamorous socialite.
♪♪
Hailee: She's having these
outrageous parties
Hailee:
and she's, you know suddenly
wearing these gorgeous gowns
Hailee:
and she's this new sort of
person.
I already told you, it's not the
right look for tonight.
And besides...
-Yeah.
I can't be seen in the same
dress twice.
Hailee:
Emily is kind of caught in the
web of it all.
She also isn't sure if Sue's
intentions are pure.
Sam, I'd like you to meet my
sister-in-law.
Emily Dickinson.
Alena: Sam Bowles, the young, ambitious,
Alena:
progressive newspaper editor,
comes barreling into their lives.
You're interesting.
♪♪
I'm interested.
Hailee: Part of her wants to be famous
and another part of her
Hailee:
is really scared by it.
This is where you will go.
Aa, I-I, I don't know.
Alena: I'm really excited
Alena:
for the audience to get to come
back home to these characters.
-I'll miss you
-I'll miss you too.
But find that home has changed.
Alena:
We get to stretch our wings and
expand our world.
♪♪
Hailee: This season takes you to places
that you
Hailee:
would never expect.
(Both)
Laughing.
Hailee:
Parties, unrequited love, a
séance.
(Thunder)
(screams)
Hailee: It's more sophisticated
and it's sexier
Hailee:
and it's more mature.
It's about self discovery
and growth and fame and the
dangers of fame
Hailee:
in the 1800s -
all through a modern lens.
Sam:
This is it.
You ready?
Emily:
I hope so.
♪♪